this video released today is the last
time police saw Constance Martin and her
family it's from January 8th which means
around about now her baby is due it's
six week health check
Constance my name's Shireen and I'm here
to speak to you as a midwife and a
mother an appeal from one of the
country's top midwives and a warning
you're putting your baby at risk by not
accessing Medical Care Shireen Nimo says
the risks are life-threatening babies
who don't sleep in their cots next to
their mums in their beds are really at
risk of sudden infant death syndrome
it's very hard to quantify what that
must be but when babies are not sleeping
in that safe recognized environment we
know that the risks go up and as the
risk goes up the amount of cash they
have is probably coming down police hope
that could be key they had a large
amount of cash available to them and we
still believe that they will have cash
available to him as of today but we also
know that with a newborn baby comes the
requirement for the items that they
require and also just day-to-day living
for both constants and Mark so we know
we're coming to a position where that
cash will be coming to an end
running out of money may seem
unimportant for a woman who left a
wealthy family
instead she chose an isolated life with
convicted sex offender Mark Gordon so
private even their pregnancy was hidden
their baby was born in this car just
before the vehicle went up in Flames the
first three days after that were the
busiest for the investigation we know
how much they spent on taxis we know
that they traveled from Liverpool to
Essex then to London before going to
Sussex we even know that they bought a
tent presumably to sleep in and after
that the investigation goes cold
police told Sky News the latest call to
their incident room came just yesterday
it's information they say they're
exploring but they admit
the pair are ahead
way ahead sadio chowdry Sky News in
London